i'm trying to
uh could you send me another invite
jacob oh yeah yeah sure
let me open up that their xbox app see
if it happens
i think it's my app is updating see i
can hear
pop-up but then i don't see anything
i did have to update sea of thieves
before this i did update sea of thieves
i think it's maybe the xbox app that
needs to be updated
did you know the xbox app is in beta
um what the hell man
get it together galleon
oh yes that's what we'll be on yes sir
how do i change how my character looks
oh
oh that's a whole process yeah i think
you have to
spend money to do that uh i've got
[ __ ] netflix
oh hell yeah you're good to go okay xbox
got updated
okay okay okay okay are you streaming
are you live i am live on the internet
hello friends i'm alana that was pretty
good
yeah someone in my chat just said i
zombie so
you know that they didn't say anything
else they just said i zombie
they have a television show tourette's
you're not
technically wrong supernatural
hi zombie okay all right jacob come on
xbox app come on
hunter there he is there's that
modularity
join me crew i would love to what the
[ __ ] is maiden voyage
this that's the tutorial that's like the
tutorial island
uh do you want to try and invite me one
more time you know just we'll just see
while um we figured this out oh no i got
it i found your invite
exchange
uh hello everyone welcome to the stream
i asked
friends to play uh sea of thieves today
because the latest update added
dogs which is the best
i'm very excited yes what's a dog's
favorite thing to say on the open sea
cause it's bark nice i was like what is
he what's the pun gonna be eddie you
didn't even make a pun you just
said the same word but like a pirate yep
that's how pirates oh who just said that
was it a pedophile did a pedophile just
show up
um and then i can send an invite
to raffle excellent
zombies is that your gamer tag
and that's the truth nobody cares
when i can't afford to make my pirate
look good yeah
that's better i sent you an invite i
didn't give a [ __ ]
but if someone in my chat said all right
hey elana is this game any fun listen
if you've never asked the question
before i get it sorry if you've never
played it before i get it
um it is like the closest
that you can get to being objective
about something objective is
yes sea of thieves is fun as [ __ ] yeah
oh here we go in my chat elvis elvis
depressedly
let's say omg streaming with scarecrow
there you go
he should have just said harley quinn
harley quinn for anyone who doesn't know
jacob and i work together at funhouse
and rahul who we're also playing with uh
actor in that uh buzzfeed top 30
uh hottest characters on tv there you go
where where did you rank though like was
it above or below five i was like
i was higher than one of the hemsworths
and lower than another hemsworth
well then the list was there's like six
of those in there depending on which
hemsworth was
higher and which was lower i think i was
in the
top 15. okay because i was going to say
if you're in the line of 15 you were
there out of pity
well when it when it happened it
happened while i was you know
at work and everyone at work got very
upset with the list
they were like you how the [ __ ] are you
what
yeah it happens to have happened to
jacob one time they put him in gq
when we were all like oh my god jacob i
can't believe you're not number one i'm
so mad yeah
so i yeah i understand a bigger
whoopsies the fact that
i i have that copy of gq and the pages
are stuck together
this is what i mean there you go
it's crazy imdb uh tourette's
supergirl yeah why it says fails to
connect to sea of thieves
that's a lie let me try and join again
i
if i wanted to rejoin my session and i
said yes and then it immediately
rejoined me
all right
yeah oh you probably that's probably in
the game i think you have to mute him
oh yeah
sounds like he's gone are you in my
apartment
um i don't know how many frames you want
on the open c
100 i don't need 144 frames do i
oh that's a lot i like that that's like
a big old number when i'm sailing the
seas
that's left at 144. all right oh
we gotta talk about that there is a new
type of gold hoarder voyage
oh my god rahul just stopped talking for
a second it's quite the celebration
okay uh it's going to be a setting
yes
crew chat volume and the danger
you'll need greg i think it's probably
that and then i just turn this the whole
way down there are ways to see i think i
just went over
to go to companies
he's not echoing success but i still do
want the proximity chat for other people
oh yes we've done it we've done it oh i
didn't go to my crew so i could have
just muted him in there
yeah let's just do that just for safety
definitely want to mute him
don't let him text don't let him phrase
you game a cod
but you're both um voices are annoying
me
well that's obama oh you still you got
the re thing on the front of the ship
yeah feel free to change any of the
decorations
okay hang on hang on i don't remember
where to do that is it this [ __ ]
uh the next one over the next one baby
am i talking to this chick
where have you locked them here i'll
dance for you
okay i did spend a lot of money on this
pirate uh sorry parrot [ __ ] but i
won't change it
how did you dance i think i already did
that um
are you on keyboard mouse my wheel are
you on keyboard and mouse i want
controller
and then this one i like
yeah big gay ship i've got i've got um
i've got a controller now
oh we're controller and look at us i too
am controlling
um okay so i just want to get dog oh
ruffle stand still
you look sort of like a knock off johnny
depp
ooh perfect oh you look sort of like
a knockoff oh i don't know
are you brown i might be
i usually if i'm a woman in a video game
i play a brown woman
you look old what the [ __ ] jacob
uh you look like a
a shitty version of corvo atana
there we go that's exactly what i was
hoping for yeah nailed it
that's what somebody said earlier a lot
of people look like someone
looks like somebody's grandma is it
oh no
oh look at that that is a scary face is
it
yeah yeah yeah all right i'm collecting
supplies
okay where to get dog i'm going to
literally google it what do i have to do
to get the job done
that's my main menu oh really
you do i have to cool don't worry
well i was assuming that i could go to a
trader somewhere and grab one
okay shop is the pirate emporium
and the pet chest oh so you can go to it
in the pet chest
yes which is down below
um well but don't i have to no no don't
i have to buy it from the place that i
would buy the like parrots or whatever i
don't have any
oh yeah you'd have to go to the mainland
you can just leave and come back again
are you sure it's my menu am i am i is
it isn't it on the um just
if i just go to the emporium uh yeah
damn it i really thought that i could
just do this in a store
which i feel like harpoon me right hole
yeah hit me with that harpoon stick that
harpoon in me
how do i is it hello oh my god that'll
do it
this is an equipment this is not gonna
happen why does it keep saying to me to
speak to gold hoarder
oh it's probably telling you tutorials
oh i do have to buy it first in the menu
is that why you all tell me it's in one
of the shops i think above the order of
souls so the problem that i have with
this is that i i always go
ages uh in between
playing this game so i forget which shop
is which and where the [ __ ] they are
uh okay one of the stores on the island
cells that's something i never knew
well i know that you can get again you
can get the pirates and stuff
is this it oh you found it oh
it's a dog here's our little shiva
oh look at the dog
look at him with his bananas where do
you buy stuff i've got loads of money
oh on this island i think if you go
right
up this path there's some stores up
there if you come back towards me i've
got the lantern
where yeah go up this hill this is here
hey cooper i'd like to buy some words
oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
this is so strange for some reason what
is happening
i don't know which one i want i think i
like oh
no chad should i let you decide which
which dog do i
which word do i get also for the record
i'm gonna have to do microtransactions
for this
which i would just like everyone to know
is the first time that i've spent money
on a microtransaction in
maybe like eight or nine years because i
have a strict
no micro transaction policy so i would
like you all to know that i am breaking
the policy
to buy a dog in sea of thieves yeah cute
though
i know it was like honestly i i've
refused for so
so so long this is what broke you the
animals
well it does it just i could like i have
285 of the ancient coins and i mean we
could
spend this time trying to get more but i
know they take a really long time to get
like the ancient points like sometimes
just show up sort of randomly so
last time i played i ran into like a
there's like a treasure skeleton that
popped out and it dropped ancient coins
that's always
totally random yeah oh is that the only
way i think so
oh yeah i don't know
i don't know what to do this is what
this is what happens if i go to a dog
shelter i'll be like but you're all
perfect
i don't what am i supposed to do
why do i change uh you need there's a
chest at the clothing store
like a clothes chest oh and uh
where is that that's a good question
there's one on the ship this
dog looks the most it might be outside
it yeah
i'm going with this one okay you got the
dog i'll stick with the cat
because i have cat in real life are you
gonna buy clothes for your dog
i can do that yeah look at my kitty
alana
oh i'm a logic jacob don't be
inconsiderate nope nope i'm already
holding it out
i'm you've made me uncomfortable trying
to show
off don't look at me you're making me
uncomfortable
you purchased the [ __ ] sorry about
that lana was the first one to do a
story
everywhere oh you're right we're
such good behavior tonight look at her
she looks she's opened a can of [ __ ]
worms
i feel like i should now we're gonna
unleash tweet rare and tell them what
i've just
yeah i look like look like good old kyle
everybody's favorite
star wars hero kyle buddy come on loden
come on mate
come on it's not more luke is a pretty
mundane name
that's true what are you got like
we've got like dune coming out and the
main character's name is paul
it's just a regular old pool yeah what's
up i'm paul
wow uh bruised it does also include
battle passes i do not buy battle passes
i don't buy dlc either [ __ ] none of
it and i just broke it to buy a dog
and sea of thieves hey hey hey alana you
have something
i buy battle passes
uh you're a muscle control i refuse
because
i don't want to poison the industry so
okay
so some of us are trying to take a
stance except for when it includes
a saddleback alsatian but i also
rationalized this before doing it that i
was like look i've put a lot of time in
the sea of thieves
and rare is basically one of my favorite
studios so
you know they can have my five bucks
yeah i probably bought craig duncan a
coffee at some point you know it's the
same thing
yeah you get that's like yeah sixty
dollars worth of microtransactions to
make up for that
why is it not previewing what my
character looks like
it's been a little while so i don't
remember the answers to any of your
questions
where's the dog i wanna see the dog oh
i'm holding him oh my god wait where are
you
buddy oh look it's a big old dog hello
here hold left sugar
look at that one works too i'll give you
a pat
i'll take that you saw my dog
get back here [ __ ] you oh i'm gonna pet
him it's so cute
this was worth it the five dollars was
worth it
i'm sorry i have to do it once jacob
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is going on why is that showing you
what my character looks like the
noise he made oh look
look everything's okay
there i oh you so i didn't know you had
that in you jacob
and oh my god i'm so sorry
saddleback alsatian um you're the best
thing i've ever seen
i'm so sorry that that happened to you
and now i
you know my trust for you fades on a
daily basis jacob
literally every day i'm like this
[ __ ] is up to some [ __ ]
well now you've just done it to your own
cat it's not it doesn't make it even it
just makes you an animal abuser
finally somebody's on to me look at it
look at it look at my dog
look at my dog it looks like it's dead
no it doesn't he's very animated look at
that
oh is that a real life cat no that was
my in-game cut here i like the
i hate animals oh get it away from me oh
i'm [ __ ]
what do we do what are we playing a
video game a lot of it
well this is it really stream can end
now this is all i needed to do
um no jacob the way that i tend to play
sea of thieves is i'll just do whatever
you want i'm not letting you in any of
this dog
fine afterwards i'm worried that he's
gonna get more abuse
what are you okay so
oh yeah we should do that so it doesn't
say that anymore uh how do i rename the
dog
uh go to the pet chest down below okay
got it
go to the pet chest down below
there's gonna be something that's my
relationship you sound like daisy ridley
that one's garbage garbage wow
i didn't know there was this much green
in the whole galaxy
that's really good she sounds very
generic
uh do you have to buy one of his like
where is or whatever dad no
it is i'm i'm never i'm not used to
being on a ship this small jacob
yeah the three three person ship yeah
where is tennessee besides the boat it's
the motion in the ocean
nice there it is it's like
it's this one with the little uh
feathers on it oh my gosh what should i
name
him where's
dog i just named mine after my real
animals
i'm not gonna name it apple eye dog chat
that's terrible
what chunk is pretty good i like chunk
chunk the dog pause
on the quest pound doom paul
yeah paul from dune should be the full
title
all right i like chad lee shadow is a
cute dog name what was that
chadley chadley yeah
hello cannonball is also pretty good for
a pirate dog
yes especially after his first trial a
couple of you did that to him did you
hear him howl because i [ __ ] did
sorry
roll makes me naughty
like a grumble of discomfort if i've
ever heard one no it wasn't
uncomfortable
no that was definitely uh man's just got
a bonus sound
oh okay bruce lucas treasure
um i don't know what i look like
wait are you at the clothing chest i
think i'm gonna go with cannonball thank
you
because i feel like he also looks a bit
broken
thank you either no it's not showing you
got it dude do an emote
uh how do i do an email hold down on the
d-pad and then like just place it on the
wheel and then it goes third person
oh my god yeah but it's not showing for
me either so something must be busted i
want it good
you do that's it so some cheekbones
right there wait i have hair
why isn't the hair equipped he's just so
cute
well that's it that's the vanity chest
right
look at that dog look at he looks at me
oh
i can't believe how happy this is making
me like
what put it down i'm not gonna shoot out
of a cannon i promise
are you gonna burn it no i'm gonna play
it a little song
okay you can play my dog a little song
cannonball please enjoy the music of
this man
there we go do a little dance
more and it's this
i bought this oh
this is five dollars was worth it i've
come back around on micro transactions
we are now pro
micro transaction let the spending spree
begin
this is
the dog is dancing the dog is dancing
i'm missing it
yeah you're fixing my hair classic
rubble
frankly um
oh well he's maybe not now there we go
that's it
rahul rahul oh he's talking about
yourself
where's barry i'll make him dance with
the cannonball the dog wait my
partner's outside won't say okay you get
that we'll make our pets dancing very
proud of you
we're a dog my burrito bone
very privileged pirates
uh i don't know where dog went does he
just like hang out by himself or what
where did he follows you
oh is he following me cannonball
did you already run away from home
sometimes they climb up on the deck and
like sit on stuff
oh gosh i'm sure where he is oh gosh no
i jumped into the sea
that cat is very upset i keep thinking
it's the real world cat
cannibal i'm sorry
get back here where's barry
there he's sleeping on the helm oh he's
too will he dance even though he's
sleeping put that right there
there we go
there we go now they're dancing wait
where's barry oh yeah
incredible incredible i love it this is
everything i ever wanted
when there's a burrito
i feel like i would probably not want a
burrito bowl
if i was hungover
i'd go straight for it no i don't
i don't think i generally want something
that's fried
there you go like something like a
sponge i'll tell you what i want
whenever i'm hungover it's like
if i'm in england it's going to be the
english breakfast you know
sausages eggs um but in america it's
gotta be denny's or something
oh yeah which is like gross in any other
circumstance
except when you're drunk or hungover
also i put a voyage down for us to vote
on down below below the steps
oh okay sorry i was distracted by the
dog
like a pirate sailing game yeah we are
uh
[ __ ] for quest
okay so this is a new type of quest i
don't really know anything about it
sweet
yeah they've been compass we're good
about updating this here video game
oh yeah if you look at your like quest
items we have a gold compass that i
guess will point
towards where we need to go why did you
just y'all look out rahul
repair the ship prepare the ship and the
buttons
i think the ship's probably fine um
okay yeah tell me where to go west
west yeah i got to go around the island
on the anchovies let's
raise that anchor oh no that's lower
so was it already out it was hey
i would prefer to thank you i appreciate
it all right northwest
westerly i wonder if your chats got
upset for that i didn't say sailrite
drive
nothing yet technology
all right okay uh i can't see eye on
your gps
yeah gps yeah i'm keeping a good eye on
that gps
so i guess i just keep looking at that
oh hello uh yeah you're gonna need to
look out for uh
roxanne ting for me because my
visibility is quite
low okay it's amazing
yeah yeah this game's water is
ridiculous
i'll go up to the crows nest
yeah what what
what my chat did i
read mike rahul did you do you sail your
car
and uh drive bugs so what's up i do have
my car
out there okay
uh heading north it looks like
i'm not great at it that's why i just
say yeah
and almost nothing else yeah jacob's
fantastic at it oh mom's really good at
it too
i should have bought somewhere if he was
down the stream tonight um i think he's
playing
destiny right now wow real role reversal
do you feel like you've been cuffed
yeah honestly
nope okay how do i avoid them just go
straight it's straight down right here
and just go straight
straighten out i mean yeah
genuine question oh wait no this is the
island this is the island
i do get seasick
that's a long way to swim y'all no
no there's a robo there there is a robot
there okay all right so this compass is
weird
because okay it just points to where we
need to go there's no map or anything so
we just need to eyeball it
so it looks like this is the place
interesting
yeah it's in your quest items if you
look there it's like a golden
company would you get going your pirate
great reference did you just make a
reference yourself and then
say to yourself great reference
you're not wrong it's the delivery the
delivery sold it oh a skeleton just put
me in the ass
boy i was like
uh yes donald glover the original oh no
oh you you cleaned them up dad uh i
really want to call you durzo
um
darzo who's a character in a book series
called the night of the trilogy that i
really love but i've never seen what
dozo looks like so it's like very weird
that i'm looking at you and going oh
it's dozo
from this book series he's playing durzo
somehow how do i drop this plan
oh a lot of behind you oh he's exploding
oh thank you that was good it was very
good
oh does that you no okay
that's this banana eating [ __ ]
nice work nice work
so i'm following the compass
and oh it's freaking out a little bit
what are we looking for um i'm just
following it oh it's
it's getting twitchy
oh it just spun around right here okay
so we just dig start digging
there we go it's gonna beat it oh you
already got it you already got it
yeah where is the candidate
i have dogs
i'll give them to your stupid cat right
behind you
oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh get away
cannonball
no
okay okay so i found a fragment of a map
so i think we need to head somewhere
else now
okay yeah is there anything to steal on
this island so i'm not seeing anything
yeah check for any barrels
yeah i'll check the barrels i got a
banana for you
it's right here
oh you can just put those away use those
fish here it takes my banana so many
he left outside the door i put underwear
on
thank you uh dozo i believe his last
name is blinch
yeah i'm gonna look up fanart because i
like i've literally never seen what dozo
it is does i blind what he looks like i
really got the rowboat
i'll uh roll back to the ship if you
guys want a ride
okay so the fan art of dozo has him
looking
like in this
yeah you guys i'm doing really important
[ __ ] here so if you could uh
let me go general all right let's go i
just wanna
drop a drag [ __ ] what are you doing
what are you doing
yeah put that in there this is
apparently what dozer would look like
this is this is this is this is this is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is
this
is this put it in the discord yeah uh which
again
it's a book i've never seen him so i
don't know why
i look at you and i think that is
definitely the character from a book
that i've never seen before
uh oh you guys [ __ ] left me with a
brother
son of a [ __ ] i can't wait to get
shocked
it's gonna be great
oh let's just wave at her oh yeah
there's stuff inside the robot sometimes
and the chest in the back
yeah we got 20 cannonballs a bunch of
food there's some chicken in there yeah
there's only one cannonball for me and
he's still on the island
i guess he'll spawn yeah they just
follow you everywhere
and find a way hey alana hello
good day mate what's going down there
hey how are you doing all right
we should raise these uh
oh i fell in you didn't mean to do that
that's embarrassing
all right let's raise these sails cause
they're pointing straight at the island
so it seems like we have to find
multiple pieces of this map and that
leads us to somewhere cool
okay so do we have a next place to go
yeah the compass is pointing somewhere
else now okay
uh it's gonna be in my
uh equipment quests
uh that was battle of the heroes
wait hold on i'm confused that's
imperial march yeah
[ __ ] in hell
oh yeah if you hold left bumper and then
hit a that's where the
compass is can't be equipped left bumper
a
okay so so
south west yeah yep let's raise that all
right
yeah yeah
uh somebody might shout out is this the
new vault quest i don't know is it this
is
oh there you go whatever it entails
oh i thought this anchor was just really
heavy but it turns out i'm just alone
yeah i'm sorry rubble's out here dancing
and eating chipotle
shitty pirates oh it's all good yeah
i fired it with priorities
yeah not helpful i didn't come here to
like
you know be part of the team the pirates
all right if i want to fire this hand in
it nothing i'll do it
well yeah i have the keys the keys to
put the pet in the cannon
no you [ __ ] stay away from cannibal
rahul
rahul
don't all right rob put the dog down
roll put the dog down
and not go in the [ __ ] cannon
i'll fire him to his mom
oh no you shouldn't have called it
cannonball that's where you went wrong
i disconnected from the discord
i decided to hang up on the windows cord
so that's what i've done now
i'm just ignoring
i think is very funny but i don't know
where to go so i should probably keep an
eye on that
okay i'm just gonna keep going
vaguely in this direction he's [ __ ]
doing it again
stop stop
oh my god
maybe cannibal likes it maybe i can make
myself feel better by oh did wait do we
just anchor
okay
you son of a [ __ ] you absolute
piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] what a dick what an absolute
piece of [ __ ] no i didn't want to do
that i wanted to go
just i just want to eat i just want to
eat this tomat
all right let's go nope don't need to do
that either let's just sit in it
sit in it pirate dogs midnight you are
correct
yes i know they can't hear me obviously
milk i hung up on the discord
that was the point they [ __ ] with my dog
so i hang up my phone
so they can't talk to me now this is
intentional
oh watch out for the snake i hope
they're all gets bit by snake
there it goes all right
um whoa
there's so many of them i actually just
got chills
that's too many snake that's too many
snake
why what is this snake island i left
australia for a reason
okay we can deal with the skeletons
ah i didn't refill my ammunition
should have done that oh my gosh barrel
boy
[ __ ] i'm on fire i'm gonna go back to
the ship
right quick brilliant
brilliant brilliant
i hope you're happy with yourselves okay
i died though sorry i could revive you
oh
i think i maybe got exploded on what
yeah i think that maybe one of the
skeletons with the
the i don't know oh you didn't remember
you came off this chord
yeah i left i hung up on you so um
getting rid of my dog we assumed
correctly
oh you actually did hang up on us
correct yes i hung up on you
thank you wait raul's also dead what
happened to us
you could still revive me i'm still here
no where rahul yeah
uh jacob girls we're both dead though
why how do we get wiped out so fast the
guy exploded the thing
yeah i thought that's what happened to
me too
oh look yeah there were a lot of bone oh
my gosh
i could use my ammo give me a man where
do you go
no i have to wait for the door to do i
have food
not much okay
i made it back what go through
why are so many snakes on this island
jacob i don't know i didn't put them
there
why'd you put those snakes on the island
i ain't no stick
boy where are we going i think we're
waiting for the golden compass
y'all called though i mean you can go go
without me i gotta
get back to the island yeah i mean we're
going to the island right it's directed
that's where the compass wants us to go
look at all that
oh there's a goblin shattered remains of
our that's our robo that's the garbage
in the sea
yep there's another one here though we
got a second rope sweet
oh nervous too excellent accident
did you swim all the way here yeah it's
good exercise
don't worry about it you're modern okay
let's see
oh you got to be kidding me more skelly
boys behind you
there are a lot of them huh [ __ ] that
really just like shot you at point blank
in the face but
i guess it didn't count is that you
cannibal are you okay cannonball
ow
all right let's follow this compass here
oh hold on a minute
oh it's freaking out a little bit okay
what's up oh the
right here no must be up on the hill
okay sorry i'm following you dozo thank
you for your apology rahul
uh dozerwolf's gonna be back to you when
he feels
like he can work through this there we
go found it
he'll speak to you in october
who cannibal he's very upset
oh i'm calling you dozo it's for the
record it's durzo
like d-r-z-o but you know australia
[ __ ] okay we've got another
racist slang oh you gotta be kidding me
more floaty boys oh no they're all more
exploited
right you're right you're right you're
right you're right
oh my god there's three of them yeah
that was not a good time
oh i know got exploded got
nuked well let's see if i can get to
roll
as well thank you thank you don't go oh
hang on
okay i'm going to make sure that i eat
some food a banana
ah there you go eat another banana
uh just look in the any of the uh
barrels
okay that should do you um all right
jacob
following i think the compass is still
leading me somewhere on this island
i mean it was definitely pointing
directly at it unless it was like past
it somewhere
oh here we go another one
oh jesus are you serious still excuse me
i keep aiming badly which is so dumb
because it's not hard to aim in this
game
oh [ __ ] really
am i far enough back i guess i wasn't
you never eat [ __ ]
is everybody alive oh nope that's it
i am down banana you need a banana uh
i'm okay thank you
cannonball what's cannonball doing oh
waiting over your course come
yeah we can take that with us i've got
some cannibals and i've got some bananas
okay yeah it's certainly freaking out
for me
right now okay it's pointing a direction
again
it might be on this island yet again
well
it's pointing sort of north it's shaking
a lot though
yeah real shaky
you put that on the row boat
i found honestly chris
uh i don't i don't even know how to read
it so what does it mean
like i've played a lot of sea of thieves
but i always play it so passively that i
just follow what everyone else is doing
that
was like i don't uh
i'm beating up the skeleton captain
chris
all right i have friends who are like
oh that's not a good sound
that sounds okay there are more scouting
next fragment is on this little tiny
skeletons
these guys don't seem to have exploited
battles but they did take me out
they're are they like more strong than
normal
that's a good question this game not
usually this hot
coming out oh god thank you
they're beating the [ __ ] out of it oh
when it spins dig got it
thank you appreciate that ow
oh they got me oh
apparently it's like really crazy that
we found three
map fragments on one island really yeah
i guess so
um
there's a skull down there a nice skull
we can take with us what do i do with it
dude that back to the rope yeah but
there's like three or four dudes here
all right we got an x on this map it
looks like
on this map on the ship on the of the
dams
oh you're dead too yeah wait what do you
get to leave i want to leave
things are about to explode why there's
so many of them
are we going back to the island again i
guess maybe we are there was a skull
there i want to get
some greedy yep it looks like it's still
oh i just saw a bunch of mushroom clouds
and there's flamingo
running down the mountain look at him
how many bananas does it take to fill
your health
uh quite a few other foods might heal
you more
i think there's still fragments on this
island yeah that's what it looks like to
me
and there's a floaty one oh i've got one
too yeah you also have a lantern you
dummy oh don't go up there don't go up
oh there i missed oh jeez i missed roll
out
you're on fire again nice good save good
pirate cover
yeah you're good you're good you're good
okay let's see
oh oh oh
this is going to mean more skeletons i'm
sure are you serious
shockingly you oh [ __ ] i thought i sold
out and i just aimed another
this dude looks like he's in a bdsm oh
um oh
cool ornate carafe
what don't call me touchdown take that
take the ornate thing with us that
sounds good
cool got it okay i think we're done with
this island because the
compass is less woobly wobbly now i'm
gonna steal some stuff from some barrels
no problems
do we what you're right we do we're
super dude yep yep
yep there's a barrel man is there one
behind us as well
wait where are you who left this
ornament oh my god dude i'm taking it
i did i took an old
okay is that everyone is that everyone
yeah okay just looking through these
barrels
i already have a little goodies you want
to grab some uh wood planks there
i think i'm full on wood planks yeah i
am too
i can't it's all wood oh i picked up
barry
oh nice you could take that back to the
ship
you can't pick up this one here i'll
pick up that one you can pick up mine i
haven't got anything to pick up
we got an ornate carafe over here that's
it right
let me store it no it can't you have to
carry
i guess
seriously do they eat is that what yeah
they do right
yeah look at that the skeletons eat
bananas
there you go hey cannibals look how cute
you are oh my gosh you're perfect
okay and no one wanted to uh
no no i don't i don't support games that
are riddled with micro transactions
listen you know that i could crank up
the fan pressure to get us to do a fifa
game
fan pressure is this the thing that you
think you think matters
i think i can get people to pressure you
to do it
does that sound like a pleasant
experience like what if you just
like made it sound fun that's better i'm
more on board with this
i'm gonna have loads of people on online
pressure you need to play people with me
and it's
we're gonna have a blast great you're
gonna forget how i forced you to do it
okay uh i'm going to continue stealing
things from barrels
i'm waiting on the rowboat i see that
i swear to god jacob if you take off
without us i will shoot
i mean it's not very fast oh no it's
covered in explosive barrels
oh thank you bleach i appreciate that
oh yeah for some reason because you
you've mentioned
someone in my chat yeah get it cannibal
that's your beach now that's how it
works
he was like spreads like a firearm and
he's gone
[ __ ] that dog
oh you're right you're right that could
have been bad but he would have deserved
it
that's true where do you want to put
them
i'm putting them over the crows okay
where does the
chalice go oh you can put it wherever
yeah let's put those down below
yeah back that ass up you just slid
right down onto my face
yeah you take someone in chat what oh
yeah because you were mentioning
fifa i guess they were like you should
play rocket league which i feel like is
the thing that happens really really
really often is you ever heard of rocket
league
okay what direction am i sailing in um
south west dish south west
ish my liege
yeah kidding me
wow thank you it's good for morale yeah
i appreciate it
jacob's really back there doing hard
work pushing that anchor
real slow back there and you're just
dancing very good very good
that's that dance for me all right
all right south west there'll be big
rocks
uh just tell me which way i should go to
avoid the rocks
uh that's good just heading that
direction okay
uh rahu is not streaming uh jacob is
streaming
which is what is it jacob
jacob jacob jcob full
oh is it
got it yeah only net
that sounds believable
[ __ ] okay yeah
of course yeah but he's being piratey i
respect it but also it's not helpful
drive it yeah just [ __ ] steer it left
mate
you got to go around this big rock hey
rubble you want to help me raise this
mainsail up like halfway
get a little more maneuverability yeah
you got to go to the other side though
just kidding i already did all right am
i heading for this large rock let's go
around it
there's a little island in the middle of
all these big rocks so
i continue to go poor yes keep going
good job thank you here we go help me
spin the spin the sails all the way to
star
yard yeah
yeah he's asleep i think he went to like
do his t
or something you [ __ ] prince that's
why you don't play video games with
british people
like i've got to go get my tea
excuse me mum's calling i got a job at
the library
i think the lamest thing that i do is
make references
like like they're in jokes yeah to sun
dude which is like
making references to your own tv show
it's but like in the tv show
that one
pedophile
oh john was on fire that day all right
we done did it am i going to this island
i did it
yep john i don't know if you need a
robot jacob's always a
warning yeah i'm starting to think that
it's you that does that
to jacob
i don't think that was there was no it
wasn't an independent variable situation
it was definitely
causality whoa ah i got snaked
oh gosh they they don't attack you if
you play music right
or am i am i crazy i feel like that's a
thing no that's real
cool uh so that's a barrel am i just
gonna stop being poisoned or
no yeah that went away don't die turns
out snakes pretty inefficient
wish i'd have known that when i was back
in the homeland
uh i'm gonna see if there's any goodies
in this pro boat
there's a lot of cannonballs if you've
got room a lot of candles oh i forgot to
stack
them last time so i i'm i think i pull
up uh let me go back to the boat
and um drop some [ __ ] off cannonball is
pissed all over this island too [ __ ]
snakes man
oh my gosh was he so brits on hard mode
i like that a lot that's very good
snakes all over this island [ __ ] it
snakes out here
yeah no that's a big girl there
i uh i'm not even afraid of snakes i'm
from cairns
which is a particular part of australia
that
is very humid which means that it does
have a lot of snakes i believe that's
why at least we also have like
crocodiles
stingrays got great white sharks the
whole shebang
uh kansas got all of them and uh oh
oh no it's just raining um i used to go
i'm going back over hiking in a
particular mountain with my mom all the
time
going inventory um that had snakes on
the path all the time so i'm just like
used to hanging out with snakes really
being like no it's just a snake it's
fine
just let it pass you'll be okay no
worries about it
spiders though they can go [ __ ]
themselves yeah not a fan
not a fan all right still a lot of
cannonballs on that row boat
yeah i'll head back and grab them yeah
i'm gonna make another trip as well i
think two more trips will do it
all right oh boy that storm is upon us
it'll be fun sailing out of here
that's okay you for doing that
scooterman gaming
i don't think anyone realizes quite how
difficult of a job
my mods have because i don't have um
what is it nightbot yeah
because i don't have a bot set up really
like
what is it um my mods do that and it is
truly wonderful of them i don't deserve
you
um nope
uh it's going to be the robot chest is
that right oh my god there are so many
why
i don't know why this random robot
that's randomly here is what i'm
wondering is like
good question what is the logic
i like the ones that look like christmas
trees ah
why are there so many snakes this is
the snake islanders and they just keep
[ __ ] showing their heads up out of
the water out of nowhere
it's like something like that let's see
snake
[ __ ] so rude
i uploaded this youtube video today but
uh it was a
sponsored video for ubisoft for that uh
what is it immortals phoenix rising game
um which like i was really uncertain
about before i played it and i was like
i will maybe do this video if i can see
gameplay like i want to know what keep
doing it the wrong way around
what it is and agree that i would like
it before playing it whatever i did
but i called the video
um i had a good time playing it it's
very breath of the wild which is really
cool uh i called it let's
eat some trolls and i keep being like i
should probably should have just gone
with like a normal title but i did it
like
out of nowhere just such a stupid
such a stupid title for that video like
i should probably change it but whatever
we'll see we'll see how many people in
the noise yeah
whatever all right pretty much i'm
raising up these sales we can do a
little spinny
okay
hey where the heck are we going to go
next oh wait yeah let's go where
what do we do now then so we gotta
find this hail brave marina on a worthy
quest
the sunken grove has got to test reading
this map at the barnacle chests
to the northeast is wise another clue
yes
it does disguise ah here we go this is
all
faithful aisle it is all right just tell
me where to go
you got it pirate daddy
is that above or below
oh [ __ ] should we take the explosives
out of the
nah we'll be fine the lightning though
jesus christ
jacob i mean if we take them out of
there then they'll just be down here i
want to keep them
okay okay
okay buddy whatever you say if i hold
our discord anymore yeah rubble's
getting his teeth yeah he's getting
the compass is doing the spins ah that
means the storm is getting crazier
all right i'll jump yeah
he comes back and he says my tea is just
brewing in it
yep riley you were almost struck by
lightning i saw it
yeah you really yeah
okay joe that knowledge embodying
thank you for your service
all right yeah i caught for a while yeah
i'm going to just head in this direction
but because my compass isn't working
it's not going to be very consistent
yeah
this happened okay sounds
fun
probably calling the queen or whatever
oh there's cannonball how's cannibal
doing
i spent five dollars on you great i'll
pet him
look at that cute face i reckon i'm
gonna have nightmares for breaking my
code tonight yeah right
spent money
oh okay wobbly
how do you do that do what what happened
i like because rahul's not as familiar
with playing the game
it's like he's a drunk pirate all the
time
drive the ship as you would say and i
will
help so just keep going in the direction
that you're going just you can't see
where north is so it's probably
like this is working for some reason
here just starboard
this is hard right towards the starboard
oh is this just in here because it's
rained
is this we don't have any leaks do we we
took in a little bit of water from a
hole
i'm just going to mentally yeah hard to
starboard just hold it that direction
we're going the opposite way we need to
go
stop it i mean uh
oh you'll have to because he's an actor
you'll have to speak in like stage right
and stage left
oh otherwise he doesn't understand
directions oh god
head to keep the sun on our left i mean
port
that's another hole i have a name
oh my god where am i am i going in the
right way now
well it looks like there was treasure we
just passed there which is devastating
but uh uh you need to do a u-turn
oh my compass isn't working either jacob
oh mine's working now
well it's not working yeah oh god the
ship is so upset
oh no we've upset the ship
we'll try to put the legs back on his
sex doll yeah thank you nell dogs cam i
have taught cannonball
well what is a common a bit huge
recently spent twenty dollars for some
robes and guild wars too but were they
sick robes though
all right [ __ ] heading north we got to
turn back into the store
great that storm is wet
the giant black abyss
i think you can see black
might still be peeing on that island
look at him go sweet old cannibal
now i want to get a real dog and name it
county all right
great yeah probably
actually what are you a cat's name jacob
uh
mike our cat's name is barry b-a-r-r-y
oh yeah it's like
it's like in game barry yeah yeah
barry's cooling for casting
for real
all right he's gotta head this way for a
while yeah i like the idea of a cat
having a
hyper-masculine name yeah just a human
name
yeah my cat's name was jazz
jazz yeah which was it was actually jazz
which was john alana
soros susan um so j-a-s-s but we just
renamed it to jazz because it worked so
it was the family names
thank goodness there's a job in there
otherwise i would have just been ass
this is my cat ass
okay we gotta turn about 90 degrees to
the to the north so
turn the port what's that in uh after
time stud
stage left there you go there's also an
outpost straight ahead
to our board so don't crash into that
that sure
is it's actually pretty close my left
foot now
yeah i uh because there's so much smoke
um this is a real thing because i have
asthma oh my god
you guys have probably seen me do this
before but uh when my asthma is really
bad i drink coke
specifically mexican coke uh because
coke is really good for uh
the specific caffeine compass looking
for working yeah
so i always buy mexican color all right
head north but when the air quality is
bad because that's the environment we
live it though um and then
some because it's real [ __ ] bad i
hope everyone's safe
you're upset about your tea
oh no my tea is too brood let's be
called the queen
i'm gonna hold on some cannonballs just
in case we end up in a fight [ __ ]
the genius oh intro me
oh my god you don't know about barry no
not yet
oh you're very good actually jacob yeah
jacob kind of has
map very vibes i don't know did it take
shots really far away
yeah i mean the way that you just said
really is burying that barrier actually
fat that sleep is still directly ahead
of us
is this going to be a real human slip i
think it is yeah
the cannon is loaded isn't it yes boss
fire fire the
nuclear weapon hey rahul turn uh
northwest
okay they're turning they're turning
around yeah it might be
they get a better shot at us we're
aggressively sailing towards them
i'm like the feminist um millennial
yeah turn to port
away from the ship i think that was a
cannibal but the game like dropped
frames to me that for some reason i
didn't hear a gunshot
i think they're going away yeah maybe
we're fine their own thing yeah
um yeah this storm is falling it's
everywhere
yo we really make sure you go a hard
[ __ ] left here boss
would you be stage right
okay we're
oh
what does it sound like when you do
cockney rahul i don't think i've heard
you do that before
yeah you have i've heard you [ __ ] me
rhyming slam but like can you just do
cockney
god we're doing a u-turn oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the zombie episode yes hi zombie
zombie
wow
uh yeah jacob is is expressing concern
but he's doing it politely so rahul's
not paying attention
where do we need to be going we need to
go north we're going south
rahul i'm taking the [ __ ] [ __ ] back
over i gave you this job because i
thought that you would be able to do it
and it turns out i was wrong excuse me
i'm in charge of security here all right
you can stay on the helm
yeah that you're forgiven for that yeah
dude turn around
turn around that's okay
just turn around i'm looking at the map
to see which way we're finished uh how
are the sails right now
um it's a sound it's too sideways once
we're going north we'll figure it out
let's just look at a sleepy cannonball
right
here a lot i can look at the map you can
see the route we've taken
the map you say yeah dude look at the
dotted line
what oh my god seriously rahul i was
like we'll give him this job it'll be
easy enough for him to do
how could he go wrong and then we've
been in a storm the whole time
that's true but also he's incompetent
oh i don't know straight now it's the
best idea um uh we're heading directly
into some large rocks left left
go left you're gonna go left i'm gonna
have to go i'm gonna have to go are you
gonna go
uh that's all right that is why i'm
standing up here
in between occasionally walking back to
look at cannonball oh
hello that's fine we're good we're good
i want to harpoon the rock to swing us
around
nice drift king tk
okay there we go it looked like you
missed but i guess
you didn't look at that turd you we
could also do a hand breaky
you you just [ __ ] drop the anchor
there i think we're going to shop time
we're pointing directly north now hey
cannonball what's up
okay they're uh turned turned apart
yeah somehow our barrels haven't uh
blown up they did mention that
yeah all right we need a 90 degree turn
to the
to the left elgin our left side go north
we need to turn directly north we're
facing east right now
okay yeah yeah well uh well there's an
island right there is that the island
we're going to
it's a big ass island my tea has gone
cold i must tell the queen
is it a is it a big island to our left
yeah that's the one yeah directly to our
left side that's the other way
hang on i just had to move my webcam
because i moved back and you could
almost see my cleavage
and i just thought of that dude i know i
know i know
i know but then i thought about that
dude that i found on a
reset era the other day who insinuated
that um me
wearing singlets is just as bad because
it makes men um think that they're
almost going to see cleavage and that
that's intentional and it's my fault
you tricked those poor pools are you uh
some do you have my stream on right now
mute it i can hear myself talking oh
there's a rock in front of us
oh oh boy i'm dropping oh oh oh drop the
anchor drop that drop
yes you are
that's what seriously this dude's logic
was she doesn't show cleavage because
she wants you to think she's going to
show cleavage and that's my fault and i
was like
how can you be this horny and have no
self-awareness
you don't have it all that blood gets
built up and you get mad it's ridiculous
he's like she knows what she's doing do
i am i just not wearing things that show
cleavage or cropping it out
is it that i'm trying to tantalize you
is it
internet siren i'm the only one out of
the three of us with my kids
true that's true you also in theory
make money off of your appearance um
in some way at least not my talent
no aren't you haven't you done like
modeling and [ __ ]
what haven't you have you not i feel
like i've seen you do modeling
oh never mind then oh i'm blushing i was
pale pageant in high school once really
yeah it was when i decided to be out
going
do you have pictures of that uh yeah
they're not that exciting
yeah they all like a tucker i would
really like to see that
i'll find you guys some pictures biggie
okay we gotta find this treasure it's
here
okay so are skeletons yep there's an
army of skills and i once again [ __ ]
forgot to
thank you i like how from what it looks
like when you're reviving me you're just
kind of sort of
waving your arm around lazily like how
you do it
oh my god i hope there's some food in
these freaking barrels you just ate some
bananas
where is cannonball oh yeah
uncomfortable
it's sad how happy it makes me oh jesus
there really was another one
ah [ __ ] oh no are you dead
yeah you got me immediately again
i have never died this much playing this
game before
tonight that's cannonball perfect boy
and i have no food did you find food
nope just cannonballs
and cannonball [ __ ] nice all right let's
get up this hill there's some good boys
for a good boy
i have like no health so mm-hmm
please let these there's some barrel
cute food in them there's one banana in
this one i'll leave it this has a
coconut
our
oh you got your tea did you my irish now
that must be nice
just drink it some tea okay how the heck
do we get there
all right what's the mission uh that map
that we found all the fragments
yeah you drive boats and you do missions
classic pirates
we're on that island and we're looking
for the x okay
i don't know where you are but uh
if you're on the island you should see
our names oh i can see the ship from
here
oh you want to help me kill captain door
balloons dude i thought you'd never
[ __ ] ask
look at this look at this cuck yeah beat
him up take his
money give me your lunch money
yeah we'll get there oh well you're
right there
he's really taking this like a [ __ ]
oh he dropped a little purse okay let me
take the skull
there's also a creative exotic here and
a ruby over here
yeah do where do we put the robot
uh around the corner yeah follow me grab
those and follow me
oh [ __ ] where's the rowboat i'm being
chased and [ __ ]
oh
i like it oh my god why are there so
many why they all have guns oh my god
it's a firing squad
oh cannonball what's wrong oh buddy
oh you don't you keep going you need
okay i'm just gonna keep running
oh i'm out i'm out i'm pissing out
it's not worth it cannonball
why are you crying bye
get yourself to run i think i'm running
the right way
where are my six yeah i like the pigs
there's somebody at the door there's
somebody at the [ __ ] mat fairy dude
where the [ __ ] is the boat i did i go
the wrong way
it's not any closer than it was before
uh don't stop rule in the skeleton
behind you when that one has a
boomy i'm gonna get shocked yeah like if
true busy making the video game team
yeah you're supposed to make a left
harry to
do you think i could get matt barry to
come on play watch listen
probably probably not probably i think
he'd probably pass on that
yes i can hear you clem fandango troy
baker is more famous than matt berry
are you guys swimming all the way to the
ship yeah i didn't know where it was
that's why i'm swimming
um i was like [ __ ] it i don't i like a
nice swim uh is matt
is troy baker more famous than matt
berry
oh maybe because of what we do in the
shadows an interesting question
oh wait who what's he doing why not we
do in the shadows
yeah the show or the no we're going to
start it soon though
you should it's fantastic
okay good so i'll familiarize myself
with you have you seen the i.t crowd
jacob oh yeah he's in the i.t grub
it was a little while ago oh okay i know
who matt berry is then
probably but his tv show if you go on
netflix you can watch the toast of
london
well why is there water okay somebody's
recommended that to me before yeah so no
no no no no but how is her name spelt
jacob
t e r a h oh it's
terrible it's terra so so i literally
had this the other day where
you you you you call her tara the way
that americans pronounce
t-a-r-a which rahul and i would say is
tara
sorry yes but you say tara but that's
the way that americans say taro so
i only saw her name written out when you
did it for her birthday the other day
and i was like oh
her name isn't tara yeah it's literally
tara which is actually a really cool
name americans aren't distinguishing
between
tara and terror right i've never seen
anyone called
tara before like that's that's a really
is it short was it your fault
her parents named her terraform
they're real big fans of civilization
that joke was too naughty i'm sorry
uh
but yeah i didn't know that uh somebody
in my chat said tara flop
i told her to make that her like gamer
jack once
that would be really good um
my friend terry her username is
pterodactyl oh is that rebel
oh tara she's delightful she is yeah but
we haven't seen our agents
i agree i remember the first time
i met her was that a party cool story
is
yeah whose birthday was that we were in
like the blind barber
that was adam yeah that's what it was
i'm still looking for this [ __ ]
treasure
but yeah i remember that that was fun
adam levine
yep that's our adam
oh rahul what have you oh
all right well it's not going well it's
not going well it's not going well don't
lana you're gonna die no i'm not the
skeleton can't swim yeah
how's the how's the treasure hunt going
it's fine
look he's stuck am i gonna blow up
the robot if i blow up the skeleton with
the tnt okay
okay let's make him walk away a bit
i just don't understand what the radius
is on these dynamite barrels that's my
problem
stay away it's bigger than you think it
is every time all right we got him and
nobody
died i'm proud of us that was not okay
oh the robot might have food in it all
right no i don't have any food
i think i would put him away i don't
even [ __ ] remember what i'm doing
anymore what am i
why why am i here you know this island
is so big i'm trying to figure out where
the hell this x is
oh we still haven't even found the
treasure here no
skeletons uh ninja waffle production
said i don't mean to bother you but is
this game better than when it came out
on launch i was thinking of getting it
once i get game pause again
well listen mate once you have game
pause the game basically free
so get game uh game of thrones
um yeah you get master chief the master
chief collection
um yeah pretty much every xbox exclusive
but point being yeah
i think this game is consistently
improved it is way better than it was on
launch
you also on game pass you get um what
are you some kind of [ __ ] chill
oh no no you know it's gonna be bad
destiny and his expansions are in game
pass in november
yeah when's when's the next expansion
jacob i'll it'll be back to my playing
destiny for a month face
it'll be november it's always it's
always november that i play destiny for
a full month and then i'm like cool what
if i did
other things now yeah oh no
oh you're right okay back up rawhole get
him
nice everybody's talking like a couple
weeks before cyberpunk comes out
oh cyberpunk oh it's coming out
oh yeah you can kill the skeletons that
are holding oh maybe that's what
happened with the other one though
that's why
there was no explosion this one no no no
no
no
no no that's worth money we can sell it
we can sell it you can set the views on
them too
oh sweet okay if it's like right trigger
i think we'll uh
light it yeah cannonball you're so cute
don't worry about that sound
where the hell is this stupid chest okay
there's another one there's another one
all behind you
oh [ __ ] i'm worried about what happens
if he blows up the other two
you feel me [ __ ] you really went for it
didn't you you really [ __ ] went for
it huh
huh
yeah i was on fire so i just failed
what's going on down there
you [ __ ] he was like let me just
shoot this one so it blew up the other
two you son of a [ __ ]
someone [ __ ] that was my getting i'm
getting my bearings right now
hey alana when you come back up here
i've got banana
is it
i think i found it guys okay you cut out
butter
i don't even know what i just said i
said in and in its entirety
great thanks rahul
appreciate it okay thanks dude
this guy's running i'm just trying to
reassure you guys yeah
thank you everything is okay what is
this
pick up skeleton chest i thought you'd
never ask that skeleton just had nothing
in it
oh you guys all the chest though oh hey
buddy yeah it's true oh we can put stuff
in the chest
and sell it put the cannonball in the
chest
okay i haven't had my air conditioning
on today because
of the smoke yeah you hold barry i'll
dig oh my god if you pull the trigger
you
pet the cat yeah can you
yeah you're telling me i can pet
cannonball
you have a petting cannonball and then
pull the right trigger
oh okay i found the key
okay okay we can get back to the row
boat now
we still have a rowboat yes yeah
you want to check what's going on so i i
found a
uh a uh
key inside the chest that we can take to
another island that has the fault on it
sweet you know all about vaults
of gloss and
destiny references
oh god this is gonna take full damage ow
i think i broke my legs that should be
fine okay you'll have a pirate limp now
you will
yeah when does it go away
in theory i could put the stuff in this
chest and then carry it
to the ship oh i fully broken my legs
i don't know that you'd do that in this
game yeah now it's coming
yeah i was like limping and dragging
huh
i'm gonna okay i'll save you gutty lad
there's all blunt
where are these [ __ ] what us
yeah i'm here when you're sailing away
where are you
what does i'm here mean oh they are
jacob do we lose jacob he's talking to
his chat jacob
jacob jacob
he died oh no i'm just joking around uh
what's up
bro are you on the boat yeah
all right so we got to go to devil's
ridge which is quite south
yeah can you adjust the difficulty i
don't believe you can
no but you can almost adjust the
difficulty by
hoarding [ __ ] on your ship because the
more stuff you have the higher risk you
are of getting a kraken which
is not a good time it's all about being
prepared
the kraken will come at when we least
want a kraken i've never beaten one
i have before but yeah but like you're
like a pro
gamer so like yeah of course you [ __ ]
have
i know i've almost got my game i'm
graduated being a gamer because i
started playing dark souls yesterday for
the first time
how's that going for seventh season on
fifa
okay cool that'll be after dark souls i
have to scale up in difficulty i'm
surprised that you've never played them
because you love sakura right
yeah that girl was my first souls board
game no way what made you play sakura
then i just thought it looked cool and
people were saying it was cool so i
played it and i was like oh this is
awesome peer pressure
did you brag about it all of them
yeah that's why you play fifa you're not
good enough
okay they really say that uh fifa is the
true dark souls that's what the game
must be saying
it's the dark side go play um
against barcelona with max this is yeah
um okay i think i think city is gonna
win i think liverpool is gonna get
second
i think chelsea's gonna get third i
think that
uh united is gonna get fourth and i
think arsenal's gonna get fifth
wait [ __ ] who's that yes awesome
that's the team you support jacob
oh [ __ ] okay gotcha
okay i think he's like [ __ ]
that's like oh wow is that just like a
fun nickname or something
the fun nickname yeah yeah all right
she's very comfortable
all right we just need to go south for
about 30 minutes
uh bad francis in my chat ask why am i
not petting the dog
so it's a good it's a good question all
right hold on i'll hold the thing
thank you yeah that's how you talk
okay what do i do i have to put him down
right right trigger hold right
well i know that i can do it when i'm
holding him i've already done this oh
oh yeah you can't do it yeah but you
could do it with the kitty and it proves
and i hope you know that i've gone in
the wrong direction just for this little
moment it does mean a lot already you're
taking the scenic route
here we go straight because there's an
island in that right next to us we gotta
go between these rocks here
they're still clear that island there
might be some shallows
just the best good boy cannonball
to get around you are worth the five
dollars head straight south after around
this island
fish do you want this back yeah i'll
take that back and give me that [ __ ] all
right
of course we're sailing right into the
wind so this will take come here
if you you [ __ ] be nice to cannibal
are you going i'm stroking the [ __ ]
look you're not being very nice about it
you're stroking him a little bit rahul
they hate it so much where's the [ __ ]
cat where's barry
i've decided that canonically cannibal
really likes cannons that's
that's so that's why we called him that
to help myself from
crying
i don't know where fairy is barry
barry oh no there's cannonball again
oh he's licking you on the face and then
you go and you do that thing
she's such a good boy though
i want you to hear his scream it's so
[ __ ] up bro
barry
yeah have you heard barry scream here
yes are you a [ __ ] sociopath bro
no i love barry have you heard barry's
scream
yet hey jacob let's do them at the same
time someone in my chat said rahul
thinks they're playing the last of us
too i see
oh no there is a big silence straight
ahead of us
sick oh the dagger tooth out post
training we want to go around that
if we could drop all our treasure off
here oh is this an outpost yeah let's
drop the treasure up
let's tell somebody where's barry i've
loaded up cannonball
okay here goes barry ready
three two one fire
i'll crash this [ __ ] ship i will
crash this [ __ ] ship
here we could just uh we could stop here
and take the robot short
stuff [ __ ] trucks
all right all right let's grab all the
treasure
this was the devil's rich gold key i'll
put that on a barrel over here we leave
that
and then we take everything else i've
got a treasure chest here i can fit
stuff inside so
i'll put things in it excellent i'm
gonna take this gunpowder barrel because
gunpowder being on the mast
makes me nervous ah
there's some exotic silk down here we
could bring exotic silk
oh my god uh yeah let's throw it all in
a row boat
no he says it works too yeah uh you're
right i always forget i don't know why
i just always swim um
if you just want to lower that row boat
uh where are we going there you go
to dust island yeah we're gonna bring it
to the island
and uh sell it all there
yeah see what's down below silks
that robot we can probably probably
put as much as we want wait what's up
where am i putting this spot just put it
in the in the robo it's floating can i
not fly myself
a sploosh
it's in the water yeah
let's go get some money
cool it's not the most exciting game in
the world isn't it
not yet it's gonna wait until we have a
bunch of stuff we actually want to keep
and then it's gonna throw up it can be
very exciting i think yeah
i find it too exciting
but was it too exciting enough we got
blown up ten times yeah like we've
i've died more in this hour and a half
than i think i ever have before in this
game so yeah that's some exact question
sounds like
that
i need to be regularly here every 30
seconds
oops wrong way all right you can jump
off now if you want i'm trying to just
turn the stupid boat
okay uh what do you got the silks i died
what oh did you teleport
no what that happens sometimes you get
stuck on geometry it'll just teleport
you back to the boat
oh dead but where's the silks i've got
it
dropped uh who do i sell [ __ ] gun powder
to it's one of these [ __ ]
gunpowder you sell to the
merchant i believe i don't know who that
is
will you take my gun powder sandra over
here seen any krakens like nope
okay sorry you said over here i should
follow you then
cannonball go oh
thank you honestly i don't know if i
will ever learn this i'm always like who
to sell to
much much better mood now this is what
happens when we play sea of thieves
every six months
i know it's definitely the consistency
that's a problem
i don't have to uh go gym tomorrow
6 am is pretty [ __ ] up yeah it means
i've got a gap at four
uh now i can be there at 8 00 am okay
uh this is a skeleton chest that doesn't
have anything in it maybe
you can give that to the give that to
this
to the gold hoarder guy okay he's not on
this dock i don't
believe oh yeah he's out on the beach
near the near the
what's it called with a key
yes all right let's go back to the robot
it is they get uh
do we have anything else on the ship or
is it like this give it to the gold
hoarder
where is he he's uh straight ahead
yeah look at that guy with the key thing
yep that's the guy quick let's leave
quite chicken let's leave he can hear us
bye cannonball goodbye cannonball
you are the best quick jacob quick
oh no he's onto us good catch
oops all right
oh somebody needs help
oh you gotta play eddie ball grounded i
had a great time playing grounded
actually and jacob and i last time when
we streamed we streamed from
uh fun house we like actually made
solid progress with base building yeah i
think that i just like
a full release and then there's like way
more to do in it then i'll play it more
yeah i mean they updated that's right
it's like birds now or something
yeah yeah i think i want the campaign to
be finished
generally but yeah it's cool
i really like the game like a grass
mansion we had a great time
[ __ ] those spiders though yeah those
will still always be
terrifying what are you pointing at me
i'm being hostile yeah i can tell you
you're always hostile
um okay raising sails
then let's get that anchor up and then
we'll keep going
okay what the [ __ ]
what i didn't do nothing
are we gonna well that's not gonna work
we're gonna have to do a [ __ ] ue mate
you're gonna have to do a ui
maybe i couldn't maybe i should yeah
that's i i thought that we would like it
would be more rounded than that and that
we would hit the docks but i was wrong
so um yeah our sails are up so whatever
i did i still didn't think it would be
quite that sharp but uh i am used to a
larger ship
uh so i'm going full
have you guys seen that video that kind
of went viral of the
malamute and his own is like don't work
oh
goes i think i've watched that video
like
maybe 50 times yeah legitimately he's
like
is so vocal like yeah the way they speak
yeah
my rottweiler i had while growing up was
super vocal
yeah you'd get home and she'd be like
when you click yes yes hello hello hello
nice to see you my friend your foe
what that's just what i'm seeing text
chat's john
you okay there rubble dude all right
oh thank you sketch lab you technically
someone just donated ten dollars and
said the catabol the true star of the
game you technically did just pay for
candles
i appreciate that i could buy a second
cannonball
or a second can of all works here
oh geez oh my emotionalized reputation
increase
look at me go wow
megalodon is it yup
yup yup
how do you raise sales these little
things the ropes on them
grab that and push up at least we just
[ __ ] got rid of everything huh
okay grab piano balls yeah i'm loading
everything from weather
well i guess you do need them too yeah
get wood too because we're gonna need to
patch up the ship when it gets bit
i've already got wood oh yeah that's
what i like to hear
oh nice is our ship straightened out
otherwise we're gonna keep turning i'll
straighten it
okay i've got cannonballs where is it
where'd he go
where'd he go did he [ __ ] bail on us
just now did he just show up and then be
like i don't want to [ __ ] with these bad
[ __ ]
no it's still here right you're right it
went under
where is it i don't hear it not
what a [ __ ] i can still hear it you
just made out like
the most exciting thing was gonna happen
yeah then it just
left it may have just left i've never
seen that happen before
that's a ghost ship on the horizon
there's some treasure straight ahead of
us and
okay where are the boats yeah let's see
the sparklies
yeah okay well
that was weird okay cool it might come
back we'll see
we shall see
i know i mean thing all right to the
south
i remember when i first started playing
this game and i feel like it it still
kind of has a reputation for it it was
just full of briefers
um well now i don't feel like that's
it's not no it's nowhere near as bad
like i don't think that is the defining
trait of this game though you trying to
harpoon that treasure
i got some wood wait should we stop are
we already over the top of it
oh oh well i mean we've got some shark
meat
okay what do you want to go where am i
going where am i going
south south yard oh i can see cannonball
from here
he's sleeping oh america
megalo might have gone away because we
were close to this island they go away
when we close to an island
convenient all right
don't go there is a ghost galleon
straight ahead of us though so that's
sure of that yeah
i mean we don't have anything valuable
though yeah it'll still attack us
is that true someone chat said most megs
won't attack unless you attack them
first i don't feel like that's true
sometimes it's true and sometimes i feel
like they seem to [ __ ] you up for no
reason
okay um head more
south by southeast i guess south
by south east he says all right
actually go straight southeast we can
skim around that uh
okay wonderful oh it's not my birthday
but thank you rahul
oh i'll play some happy birthday every
pirate's favorite it's technically
cannonball's perfect
we got him today
stop calling it cannibal
i think this is my favorite of the
shanties
uh who is mobility that is jacob
fullerton
that's me he streams twitch.tv
play it maybe it'll work
all right stay southeast for now i can
see that's kind of chaos in my life
here you need a harmony that's what you
need
nope i see that ghost ship though
okay we're probably safe to turn
directly south now our race
enters the giant terrifying skull in the
eye in the sky
okay
who's on the ship
yeah no you're not wrong uh do you want
to
straighten these sails out perhaps could
you maybe be useful
yeah yeah that's the thing is like we're
going straight into the wind so turn
them all the way to the
all the way to starboard turn them all
that we just started
yeah okay that's the wrong one
yeah you're on the right wheel
that's the sale as well yeah you want
the
here come back here where i am oh i got
all clear out here
right this way yeah no the other
opposite direction
it was already in that direction well
okay let's go do the back sail now
because we got to do that one still
okay god i love this pirate ship it's a
pirate ship with its ori sales
it's so green beautiful and super cool
i know oh we're still going right now
yeah bit of a bummer yep
well this is our life for a little while
like the v in my chat said didn't rahul
used to be on mixer or i am
am i imagining that what's he doing now
yeah he was a pro mixer streamer
um but since minx is shut down he's now
i'm fully out of work
all right okay
yeah real hard and then started acting
in two successful netflix shows
i panicked because once i was once my
mixer crew was over i didn't know what
to do
yeah so i became an actor it's that
simple what's that noise
what was that
i'm not sure what that was
oh i fell in the waters loader good day
good day no i can't i've missed it oh
yeah you'll get a mermaid
okay we got an island directly ahead of
us so head more southeast
more southeast catch a little bit of
that wind
if we flip the sails around hi
all up in that chat right now oh you are
in the water
yeah you're not you're not wrong
oh here we are help me spin this other
sail around
you know in the water now i mean you
[ __ ] thank you
appreciate the update
that's a useful chat it's got all the
contacts you need in it
it's very helpful for us right now i
really needed to know
so that he could say it faster than it
shows up there but still appreciate it
okay
uh i'm gonna go in all the things too
fast i'm gonna needle through the middle
yeah that sounds good throw the deal
just like beggars can you back home
mm-hmm
mm-hmm mm-hmm how do i slurred that so
yeah it's been kind of now this is like
a better camp at home
baby
said anyone know where rahul is
there he is now we know oh
amazing okay i am on the ship right
you're going between all those rocks
they're going
that's what i meant by thread the needle
i like to lift dangerous are we going
through the middle of this
yeah dude all right let's do it
ah barnacles okay our captain
one of the game oh it's just it's a c
why did you say barnacle gay what
specifically is gay about the monocle
i think that's one of my favorite things
to do as a minor inconvenience so if
someone's like oh that's cool i'll be
like what specifically is cool about it
just to put them on the spot zack and
andrew all the time by two best friends
they'll be like oh yeah what
specifically was cool about it
yeah give me details like i don't uh
sorry one of them lives in san francisco
and the other lives in seattle
and right now absolutely both of the
cities are just bright red on fire oh
yeah
that's that's all right all right
okay just knock some knocks dog
uh we threaded the needle and you
[ __ ] doubted me south
south is that big island dude look how
beautiful the water looks right now stop
it stop objectifying me stop it i'm
looking at rebels but
all right that helps no that helps
i appreciate it jacob thank you i feel
supported
sorry sorry you're a true feminist yep
i look up man's skirt
i look up man's skirt
i do this thing where sometimes i lean
really far back in my chair so my
my face takes up maybe half of my webcam
it's not even half it's such a small
amount the chair is like
the entire rest of it i love it
i'm gonna play another song for both of
you okay
okay
oh [ __ ] there's a galleon at that island
what do you wanna do
is it game of thrones is it you are a
[ __ ] embarrassment
what happened he killed himself because
he called a song from zelda game of
thrones
[ __ ] fake gamer uh where is the and
jacob
it's this ghost galleon so if we're
close enough to the island i think we'll
be okay
okay that's the island i'm trying to go
to the one with the fire
okay i'm going to raise the sail springs
get close instead of
the ball thanks ronald appreciate it
where's cannonball right now what is
this cannonball
i just got a block hey yup he's right
next to you
wonderful just where i like it yeah that
is straight towards the island
where's rahul always on the ship
i was wondering where he was help me
raise this uh middle sail up all the way
sure
thanks pal
that's a hot tip kyle said when you open
the vault you only get three minutes in
the ball before the door closes
well [ __ ] okay that's kind of scary
there you go
do i have enough bullets i only got two
bullets left oh there's an ammo just
right down here
oh yeah get food too because we're gonna
probably need a skeleton
this is [ __ ] beautiful skeletons
eating our asses for free
i don't have the paper [ __ ] all right uh
wait how do i get that much you just
look at the crate
you're really just depleting our
resources and not helping at all huh
like i've been stocking up that food
barrel
over here this [ __ ] haven't been
doing [ __ ] has he
not been doing [ __ ] all right no i've
been doing tons of [ __ ]
i'll get the key we need to go to the
east wait let's grog
to the east oh yeah you can drink if you
want
four towers in san benite the basque
cliff east beach
oh lovely that's a good time to do that
why is things spinning a little bit
that's gonna happen oh you got drunk
just now
oh oh jesus oh boy
okay where's the food let's go i'm ready
to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
look at the foods of the food barrel
whoa
it's yellow oh yeah i didn't ask you
guys if someone in my chat said ask
rahul what he thinks about the
confirmation of rey's lineage being
unplanned do you guys see that
i mean is it like so they confirmed that
they didn't know
no and i was like yeah no [ __ ] i think
that's like what i publicly commented
when i saw ign posted i was like oh the
most shocking news ever
yeah like i watched the movie and i was
like wow they just really had this show
didn't plan any of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but now it's a real
detail
but from one of the actors movie trivia
yeah i'm i'm struggling here are you
struggling with boss man
that's wrong oh yeah
i found where we need to put the key i'm
pretty sure all right
okay let's head down the beach
no rahul stop it's going to work now
while you can let's go cannonball
let's go she didn't fire herself into
the cannon again
no it's because i'm taking cannibal with
me by hand
i can't even unload the cannon oh here
we go
just pat this sweet boy oh is that nice
you give you ice cream
i'm struggling oh wait which way did you
guys go uh
oh god the skeletons are here no [ __ ]
i'm coming
it's so hot well it's not our fault you
got drunk
help me i'm being attacked by boston
bolton you really are
captain boston i don't have the
coordination
first of his name i don't think anybody
you're trying to eat a banana not i
might watch you [ __ ] [ __ ] there's so
many snakes
oh yeah i haven't seen a single snake
why are you running away skeleton what
do you
skeletons don't have fear
oh
he might still be on the ship oh
ah i'm going to fight should i take the
villainous bounty skull
yeah we could take back that though
still try to get our [ __ ] together
uh does cannibal not fight i don't think
the pets fight for you
yeah they just chill they just hang out
it's they're good for morale
which is very important in a fight
actually they will in
six months
i people in my chat keep talking about
only fans
and i'm pretty sure it's because of the
sexual chemistry between you two
um but i i've been trying to figure out
a way that i can
make an only fans where i exclusively
post pictures of dogs that i've seen in
public
and make enough money that it would be
worthwhile to give to charity
like i'm trying to figure out this
scheme of dogs only fans
content that people will pay for that's
the key
i'm working on it all right you guys
ready to open the vault
uh no hang on hang on alana you have to
find pictures of dogs
right well it would have to for me to
legally be able to make any
revenue off of that it would have to be
pictures of dogs that i took
all right and that's what i was thinking
was maybe i would like
oh sorry jacob we'll we'll let you give
us instructions in a second okay can you
stop
playing the video okay um like maybe i
could walk with shelters in l.a where i
would like go and i would take pictures
of the dogs and they would be the people
i would donate the money to is like i'm
trying to figure out a way to use that
platform
to post pictures of howables basically
you need to make the dogs with a [ __ ]
i don't know if i'm comfortable with
that
no i don't like i don't even like this
line of conversation
uh a little bit lipstick no
if you pay 30 dollars oh also am i
allowed to can you even post
oh what oh oh oh
oh my so is this the vault looks like a
latin
this looks like a vault it's like
aladdin got a job at the library
um okay well you have the key
or no i thought you did oh it's opening
oh jesus oh lord oh jesus
all right i think we've got a crap take
chest
there's a puzzle in here is that
i just took the chest and ran we should
pick it up
okay okay that's a bad idea well no that
opened two i'm just gonna drop all the
[ __ ] on the beach
yeah good thinking just pick up these
chests and put them here just run them
outside
running them outside oh god we can't
pick up which is the gold
brilliant well that takes too long
oh these turn
so it is a puzzle
oh a poor medallion can i drop it
directly outside the door i'm walking it
the whole way up because i know that
that stone did close too so it wasn't
sure how far the clothes would be
i bet that like shoveling gold into our
pockets is like some kind of booby trap
here i'm gonna uh i can see that being a
thing
all this gold there's a lot of gold in
here yeah but is it going to be my
dog uh supporting only fans
i need to return to service
okay there's a lot of stuff up here
rahul you are absolutely the person who
gets up [ __ ] up [ __ ] uh who gets [ __ ]
in a in a fairy tale because they do the
greedy thing without thinking about it
even knowing that it's probably going to
go wrong you do it anyway
yeah and the white guy's like come on
he's like no i must grab it all more
uh yeah i might be taking them too far
i'm putting them on the beach but i
wasn't sure if both of the doors closed
you know how you opened that little rock
bit
first so yeah it's probably it could be
a waste of time that door is closing
that's for sure there's skeletons
oh it is closing [ __ ] okay
what just kill those skeletons i think
skeletons just showed up somewhere
where's that last uh all right i've got
the gold
i somehow feel like rahul probably
hasn't been that helpful in this
situation
looking for this medallion
where are you putting this gold just all
up on the beach
how's that gate looking where's this
other third medallion
gate's still okay it's about halfway
actually oh [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i think i could see it
oh [ __ ] i felt
oh god i'm doing that
we need to turn the blocks on the
pillars to like
match something whoa
okay you stopped it maybe the door just
stopped for a second
oh that's good i found the third floor
medallion into solution oh i shouldn't
have done that don't push that
no i did it's my bad it's crown
chain and lock and key crown
chain oh god oh my god somebody pushed
something
i don't know what to do uh chain this is
locking that's already lock and key
isn't it it's a chest and it's a lock of
keys
then are we going to solution jacob are
we ready uh
wait are they the right symbols no i
didn't
there's four though of [ __ ] we have a
crown we have a chain
we have another chain and we have a lock
and key it's the double chains that
might be wrong
so then what's the fourth one drowning
that's walking key what's the fourth one
okay
uh is it on the wall somewhere oh i died
[ __ ] i feel like died yeah
that got out of hand quick yep how bad
uh did i [ __ ] it up by pressing the
button is that what happened
yeah oh yeah there are only three in
there i see yeah i think we press the
button when it's the wrong thing i think
it'll
be my
i think we got all of the chests out
yeah oh there's a bunch like around the
ceiling and stuff too oh bummer
i imagine like doing the thing keeps the
door open forever so you can just get
all of it
probably let's see
we got some of it
we got a lot honestly we did it was a
lot of it yeah oh my god
all right that's the spirit
fourth is the combo of the first three
[ __ ] what does that mean
oh so it's like the three oh okay so
apparently it's super simple apparently
the door always closes
it is always a three minute timer okay
um
yeah cool
it just gives you a very cool chest is
that
it all right do we have to see if we
would like to do it again or
oh i don't know let's try it let's see
if it opens up again
sorry what the [ __ ] make a panic every
time oh
nice all right i'm back at the vault
i've forgotten where you are
yeah but i'm too
ow what are you on a cliff
i'm gonna get full damage what's wrong
with you
okay yeah okay stop taking these chests
back
hey cannibal look at you bro
cool
stood in front of it and it opened on
its own i can't i'll bring the robot
over there
that's a good idea
close forever
i'm not sure well okay did we finish the
quest
well we finished it when we got the key
at the end we could have turned in that
key
oh for money or we could have taken it
here
i'm pretty sure this is kind of like a
little bonus
it'd be easy to bring the rope
where am i going where am i going i
don't know i don't mean to be going this
way
oh geez oh is anybody's a lot of does
your chat say if we're doing
if we're able to get back in or is that
it see the robot out there going out to
see
yes my bad it's my bad i actually kept
all the gold
yeah that's the yeah i think they're
saying my chat is saying it's done
okay so you ever you have your one
chance
there we go hey we got something guess
this is how we learn
this back to the island yeah there's one
close by though
shall i stop here oh fashion guardian
those brits man just so eloquent you
know the british
shakespeare on that
i'm beating up this guy yeah take his
lunch buddy
okay give me your notes and your skulls
this dog is not doing anything can you
shut the [ __ ] up
do you know what you did that whole time
fill your own [ __ ] pockets with gold
yeah and i'm glad i did because you
pressed that you got it blocked out
i didn't it happened anyway it wasn't my
fault
i think the button only made the room
fill up with water
i don't know it might happen i don't
know i really don't know
i'm actually holding my weight now
i haven't got that grogg
he really sorted his life out after the
alcohol incident
yeah alcohol is what fixed everything i
was in i was having drunk fights with
snakes
by yourself the snakes that no one else
could see they didn't even exist
uh we got a little bit of a hall here
yep that's everything yeah
it's a solid hole
five pets good day i still see you on
the ship
my good size oh now i want to donate
more than i already did
why is this storm following us around
jesus christ
yeah there's always one storm on the map
that moves around and it's
gone the whole way with us
why did i just take damage yeah we can
if we team up we can all beat it up with
our swords
okay let's do it yeah okay
it really needs all three of us just
wailing at it with swords oh shooting
yeah shooting is like so slow
it floated up nice walk it did came
it did done
it didn't look so beat up jesus
i don't want to talk about it that was
okay
there's an incident
you got a good amount of treasure here i
know i i feel like we gotta turn this
[ __ ] up immediately it's too much
treasure
yeah it's gonna be a cracking or
something
yeah it's kind of in the storm you can
see the lights on though got it okay
yes hard to the starboard
yeah i only needed that was a bit of a
vacation i think
all right let's uh spin those sails
around all the way to the starboard side
he's using the [ __ ] language again i
mean
look at him using the uh appropriate
jogging
jar what a dick jargon
let's put this little one around
all right to the north where is uh
where's rahul right now
north by north what's up wondering where
rahul is right now
curious where he is
there he is now we know where he is so
stupid
all right there goes me compass
but it's okay because i can see where we
gotta go
yep yep good night holy sit
uh yeah i left cannonball the cannibal's
probably gonna teleport to the boat
don't worry about it
special ability oh something's busted
what's up just busted
please fix please do fix
things
it's the greatest fights why even no
matter how i try to turn the ship
because he's not doing what i want right
now
oh yeah so i'm just gonna fight to fight
him
oh god we're even in this island i think
we need to go
more to the left well to the left you
think oh i think it's turning us
hold on look at the map that's the only
way i'll know
yeah yeah it's like it's to the left to
the left yeah oh wow okay going away
from it now
i thought it was hot to the right okay
yeah head uh
okay actually come help us new
i could see it though it's that island
to our left side
okay lightning just struck oh i think
the white
lighting struck
it's also raining yeah it also water
gets in when it rains
oh there it is just keep going left more
left
yeah okay
is that barry oh there's cannonball look
at his sleeping
holding that nap and the artist ron will
put the dog down
please no rubble please
uh okay this is this is gonna be outpost
right here
yep that's the one h inspired how close
are we about to crash into it
uh not that ahead
man the wind's so aggressive it just
turns me over the [ __ ] it wants
i don't have a say in any of this nice
dude
there we go nice let's throw ashore
okay
you are so cute yeah you're doing it
i think the anger is down though so it's
not going anywhere great kid
i hold my dog all i see is dog like
there we go
oh leave without me huh
oh i just can't see oh there you are my
uh
he's probably like a lot of my screen is
covered by dog right now which is
am i supposed to where are we supposed
to take this uh
good question for the gold hoarder it's
right there right next to us
i picked up a marauder's chest gull goes
to the skull
lady who's somewhere on this island
about marouana
where'd i go uh marauder still goes to
the gold quarter
who is gonna be oh
he's hiding in the bushes expecting him
to be on a different beach
okay hiding in the bushes
oh didn't mean to do that storm is so
violent goodness
gracious there we go shells
hey cannibal
up how about this one
one day i will learn this oh did i not
pick it up oh
i didn't i thought that i was carrying
something and i actually dropped it here
uh the ammo crate
i don't know if we could sell the ammo i
think you can
but i don't know if the trader on the
docks
it's not gonna be you it is you great
cool
okay wow plus two thousand
yeah that's from the ruby mermaid jam
oh well we all getting over website yeah
yeah it's a shared
profit number 20
170 thousand i haven't checked
i have 416 000
look at our loyal pets
all right all right everybody's the
board
roll's back at the ship what yeah
what's happened
oh my god oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
let's peel the water out quick oh my god
rahul you have so much opportunity to
tell us that
i thought there's one
[ __ ] he did say that he was like but
it's cause i'm drunk and i was like that
doesn't make sense
but i guess they didn't question it okay
where's the hole it's guy
what i mean wow almost oh geez holy [ __ ]
the ship almost sick oh my god okay how
did that happen
i think there's just some
yeah water that happens oh my god
oh the rain you think the rain no
not that much yeah the rain won't sink
the ship
but there was a single hole in our ship
that we didn't notice
oh my god [ __ ] now what
i mean we could wrap it up there oh wait
there's a dirt there's a
there's treasure down here there's a
skull and there's a chest
okay next to the bed almost forgot
do we have anything else who are we
gonna lock in the brig
for the end of the stream
i mean i think he knows i hate
cannonball i love you yeah i think i
know
did you just put cannonball in a cannon
again wrong is that what just happened i
heard a gunshot
yeah i heard a dog cry
for [ __ ] sake uh who do i sell this to
jacob
what's that gold lady right next to the
gold hoarder
all right i'm going to cast my vote for
the brig
hey guys come here lana you'll need to
cast your vote too
where do i do that how do i do that if
you go to my crew it's in the middle of
the night
yeah and then you know yep
i was about to hop on my [ __ ]
oh no what for your claims you'll be
locked in the brick
is he it did work right i think it
worked
oh my god is that sarcasm yeah
okay oh i have an idea oh yeah i know
what to do
oh what happened here
no no my idea was that i would get drunk
oh yeah vomit on him oh even better idea
did you [ __ ] put a hole in the ship
bro no
no rahul i think he might have
i just don't know where the hole is i
think he has oh no
there's water here yeah
all the animals are freaking but from
whence you know what i'm saying
oh no he's trying to dig his way out so
if i don't have any alcohol left because
i could fill it up here coming
yeah there's a refill let's drink some
more of this
nice and toasty it gets sauced
properly we gotta get some oh i'm all
out
of this i think i'm close
oh is that oh wow there really is oh boy
oh
walking is getting hard oh heck
oh god he killed me really
could you cut something oh no i would
all i wanted was to vomit on you rojo i
don't know why you had to be so hostile
about it
it's a mutiny from the break look out
look
i really turned all right the table's
turned there yeah yeah
he done got us it's all right i'm just
[ __ ] eating this banana
you really did oh i have no ammo
okay well that's good the ship's still
on fire though
which is less good and i'm not vomiting
yet which is disappointing
yeah you need to get there trying but
it's very hard to walk
you know what i'm saying you didn't know
i had a couple of throwable bonds
no i didn't didn't expect that i am
still on fire
oh geez just try to eat a banana real
quick
i still hear the fire rubble is also on
fire
i keep swaying into it [ __ ] it up oh
here where's the water barrel i'll put
you out
oh gosh you okay that cannonball
just trying to vomit man
oh my god you're on fire again
yeah i should have put it out with my
stomach file i don't know how it keeps
catching fire i still hear a fire oh
it's oh my god the mast is on fire
oh [ __ ]
okay okay there's the vomit am i ready
to vomit
it just happens automatically right oh i
did already love it
okay beautiful i saw the stream come on
buddy let's go
let's get volunteering on me i'm sorry
jacob i can't even see you
yeah he didn't go on me
oh at that time did i get you yeah yeah
set me on fire good it's acidic
are you okay why are you oh i'm gonna
die
oh i'm gonna die oh god two drunk hold
me cannonball
let me hold you please
oh my god oh
god there i go
i'm there nope you're coming back
this ship's moss is taking damage
apparently
all right oh yeah
oh my gosh cannonball hi buddy
i'll be with you until the end no you
won't die you won't die
you you must live good boy very good boy
oh god i don't know what to do with you
you can swim to show right little bug
a little little guy i'm gonna die again
but i don't mind
oh i can pick cannibal up from my
inventory that didn't even occur to me
there it goes there it goes
i forgot that we had that honestly let
me um
real quick just i'm gonna do here we go
oh my god it looks like i'm down but no
wait from one wait
oh we gotta go
here i'll play you out
back
it's a slow burn there we go
yeah this ship's not thinking fast
enough where's the anchor i know it like
it should it really should be sinking
faster
i just hope the dog's okay you know oh
god why do you look scared
i don't know how to actually
i think we just have to go back in about
to release from the bridge
there we go there we go he's been
released he got out he's done his time i
don't know why i did
you know i think you know
it is very much on fire
ready
i'm ready for whatever it is i'm ready
playing something it's it's sfx look at
the music yeah
he's doing a bit look at him go
it's not working very well right
you hear that
my heart will go on oh oh
oh i see what you did there i understand
yeah got it uh rolls a shark in the
water behind you but it was the road
is that that excitement that you wanted
are you kidding me
oh that might make you sick because it's
roll
well farewell holy [ __ ] it's really not
going down yeah it's just on fire hey
you know what water puts fire out
exactly
so the more that it sinks the water is
there you [ __ ] touch my dog i'll
kill you oh my god you got your dog
oh it's right there oh god
oh there's two sharks wow touch my
[ __ ] dog
i'll kick your ass and i'm gonna eat the
sharp meat again
you're gonna well you're trying to come
for me but you're having trouble huh
idiot shock oh yeah this really stuck
there huh
oh there you go jacob yeah i think that
the boat just is gonna be like that
forever
which is quite beautiful it looks pretty
cool
i'm gonna be honest all together now
i understand how they would be like
useful props i get it it just seems so
silly
look at our big gay flag look at it just
shining against the smoke you know
all together now and it's over all right
well we did it you guys yep thanks
please you failed me i appreciate it
yeah i love i'm always down to play this
game so fun
yeah and now there's dog exactly now
they're his dog
um i think it's getting lower in the
water
is it oh maybe it is now
no i don't think it is
it must not have holes in it i could
have one hole in it so it's just taking
you really long time really really
slowly if i go out to it and i start
hitting it with the sword would it do it
no i don't think so i don't think you
can damage your own ship that way
i like the spirit though yeah i like
this fight here i don't care look
all right there he goes again two apex
predators
oh you did it
oh [ __ ] it is sinking i'm just going to
do this real quick i'm just going to
blow myself up quite quickly i'm just
going to do this look at myself it's
like titanic i'm at the edge
but oh wow oh so majestic in the sunset
like that
oh good scratch and there he goes
he's chip he's genders chip
that's all right i'm just patting my dog
we did it yeah
no can't get me [ __ ] i think you're
right i think it's stuck
oh you got me
how did you get how did you chase it
down do that
in one bite yep well that was fun
guys let's do it again sometime let's
good night everyone